i never expected a day to be quite as
emotional for me as it has been
you guys won
you guys held
adam i didn't expect this would be quite
so emotional either but it must be an
adam thing today
well that pathetic display kicked off a
debate spurred by our next guest about
whether real men cry in public joining
me now is matt walsh to the matt walsh
show
all right matt what's wrong with men
showing kind of their sensitive uh
vulnerable side in public why is that a
problem
well i do think it's been interesting
that i said men shouldn't cry in public
and lots of men
have responded to that statement by
crying in public which
hasn't really made me rethink my
original assertion and by the way i
think i'm being generous here i did say
there are exceptions like
you know if if a loved one dies or you
come home from a long deployment
hugging your children you get your arms
stuck in a wood chipper
uh uh you're watching the end of the
movie rudy like there are there's a
couple other
exceptions maybe i could write out like
a publish an actual guide and if a man
feels like he's about to cry
he can consult that guide to find out if
it's a sanctioned
sobbing fit or not um i could possibly
do that if i need to
my real point though i think it's a
pretty simple one it's just
men should try to control their emotions
you could you could go too far on the
stoicism end of it we should right now
we're airing way on the other side of
that extreme
just try to control your emotions and
not cry all the time people react to
that though
it's like one of the many common sense
statements you can make these days
people react to it they don't just
disagree they react to it like it's the
most insane
outrageous thing they've ever heard
there were guys threatening to
threatening me physical harm because i
told them not to cry and they were
crying while they said it wasn't really
worried about it but
it's just it's a pretty crazy reaction
well
there are some really tough guys who
occasionally just you know the emotion
overcomes them
one of my well favorites is brett favre
okay he was retiring and he's
you know that's emotional i mean don't
women really i'm thinking
do women love that i mean they maybe
they do i mean
it's he was torn up he was so torn up he
joined the jets matt
i'm just teasing yeah i will allow that
i mean if you're retiring from a from a
from an athletic career all that
just just don't retire from your career
in the middle of the competition as we
learned this week that's another thing i
would recommend
how about crying at your daughter's
wedding it seems like that would be an
acceptable
moment yes this is why this is why i
need to publish the guide that people
can
people can consult before they and yes i
would agree that that's
another acceptable occasion there are
maybe two or three others
speaking of crying don lemon he subs on
tv
quite frequently we got to self-respect
we got a self-defense and we intervene
when you start killing us like that
i'm sorry matt
that was not when he looked at his last
ratings book that was
that was actually heartfelt
and you know and that was that was a
that was a mean comment that might make
him cry some more you know that's
we got to be careful there a lot of men
with with fragile emotion these days and
that's i think that's what we're
learning
matt i'm sure everyone's going to be
triggered by this conversation thank you
keep calm and carry tissues hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else